[Musique]
Pierre Emmanuel Valentin bonjour bonjour
nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle Serview on
aurait voulu avoir quelques détails sur
votre business qu'est-ce que vous faites
dans la vie je suis président du
directoire de laanf c'est quoi nef ah
c'est toute une histoire d'abord la nef
on vous écoute aujourd'hui c'est un
établissement de crédit spécialisé c'est
l'agrément que nous avons de la part des
autorités bancaires en France vous
l'avez eu quand notre premier agrément
remonte à 1988 et puis je vient d'être
étendu en 2015 pour élargir nos
activités la démarche avait été
entreprise par qui l'istoire de la nef
c'est d'abord un un groupe de de gens
qui constituent une association qui
s'appelle la nouvelle économie
fraternelle on est dans les années
70 et ce groupe de gens cherche à
faciliter l'accès au financement pour
des projets qu'on qualifie maintenant
d'alternatif je ne sais pas si le mot
existait à l'époque des projets dans le
domaine de l'agriculture dans le domaine
de la pédagogie dans le domaine des
médecines douces et puis cette cette
aventure militante elle s'encre dans
dans une structure financière en 1988
pour lui donner plus d'ampleur cette
structure financière elleobtient un
agrément de la part de la Banque de
France avec le soutien du Crédit
coopératif qui d'emblé le le Parin
puisque il donne à la Banque de France
sa garantie si jamais la nef se trouve
en difficultés financière par exemple
vis-à-vis de ses déposants et bien c'est
le Crédit coopératif qui garantit notre
solvabilité notre liquidité n nous
sommes constitués dès l'origine en
coopérative avec un directoire un
conseil de surveillance et puis la qui
qui est directoire mais avant ça
euh j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde sur le
mot
fraternel vous entendez fraternel par
liberté égalité fraternité ou
fraternelle
maçonnique écoutez je ne sais pas très
bien ce que veut dire le fraternel
maçonnique mais on va dire que je
l'imagine et donc vrai simplement plutôt
dans dans une acception comparable la la
la nef elle s'encre vraiment dans la
grande tradition humaniste donc
j'imagine que ça doit être proche de de
la tradition que vous évoquez donc pour
nous la fraternité c'est
euh la capacité de l'homme à voir
au-delà de lui-même et en particulier
dans sa relation avec l'argent pour
construire à partir de cet argent une
une relation bienveillante une relation
non violente une relation
entrepreneuriale
constructive ça va avec une vision
dehomme qu'on va qualifier de de
transcendante même si ce ce mot peut
faire peut poser question mais c'est
bien notre la qui est à l'origine de
cette démarche de la nef la
transcendance pourquoi ça pose la
question parce que on est dans un monde
où tout ce qui est de l'ordre
de d'une
dimension supramatérielle pose problème
nous nous nous revendiquons une
ouverture à une dimension spirituelle
transcendante même si nous sommes ancrés
dans le réel nous exerçons un métier de
banque et ce métier de
banque à partir de vous êtes comme le
Vatican vous êtes une banque religieuse
non assurément non on est dans une
banque totalement ouverte à toutes les
traditions vous vous trouvez dans les
projets que nous finançons des projets
portés probablement par des associations
religieuses mais nous sommes nous à la
recherche de tout ce qui va porter une
valeur ajoutée qu'on appelle sociale
culturelle
environnementale territoriale tout ce
qui peut concourir
à on appelle ça dans notre jargon à une
transition vers un monde plus
respectueux de l'homme et de la planète
pour pour résumer c'est notre fil
conducteur vous êtes pas franc-maçon non
je ne suis pas franc-maçon seul un frère
est autorisé à se découvrir c'est ça je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas pour moi ça
reste un monde un peu mystérieux mais je
ne je ne l'ai jamais fréquenté est-ce
que vous connaissez un monsieur qui
s'appelle Steiner oui bien sûr puisque
cette philosophie de Rudolf Steiner fait
partie de de nos racines nous en avons
d'autres mais mais ça fait partie de nos
nos racines et certains des des
militants
originels de l'association La
Nef même si je je ne les ai pas côtoyé
cont tenu de mon jeune âge mais il m'a
été raconté qu'il faisait partie
effectivement d'association proche de la
pensée de Rudolf Steiner et pour vous
donner un un exemple très très concret
hein cette pensée de rudolp Steiner a
notamment inspiré le le agricole
s'appelle la biodynamie hein qui est une
forme de vous parler de Pierre rabille
c'est ça non non bien avant pierre
rabille hein la bioninamie est assez
ancienne pierre Haby c'est plutôt
l'agrobiologie mais les deux démarches
sont sont très proche elle
s'interpénètre on est bien dans la même
mouvance he d'une culture agricole
respectueuse de de l'ensemble de son
environnement et qui est au au cœur
maintenant de la démarche bio bien
connue et qui prend de plus en plus de
place dans la production agricole
française ça vous pose un problème que
que vos racines que vos fondations
touchent à la philosophie de
Steiner écoutez c'est une des racines
hein nous avons d'autres
racines au départ 100 % du bord était
anthroposophe non écoutez au moment où
qui qui vous a rapporté ça d'ailleurs et
bien c'est la la chaîne des fondateurs
hein puisque les les les les fondateurs
de l'association se sont retrou trouvé à
la à la base de la fondation de la
Société financière en 1988 et donc des
des des écrits ont été posés euh sur la
la la vision des fondateurs de la nef
dans la la relation avec l'argent donc
moi ça ne me pas pose pas problème que
l'établissement qui qui m'emploie et
auquel je consacre toute mon énergie et
des racines ce qui m'importe euh c'est
la la compréhension que maintenant tout
le monde tous les acteurs toutes les
parties prenantes de la nef
d'aujourd'hui ont de ses racines et et
ces racines elles sont clair elles sont
elles sont peut-être un peu gangrainé
quand même non Steiner vous connaissez
son idéologie écoutez je n'ai pas je ne
suis pas un un
spécialiste de la pensée de Rudolf
steinerah non plus vous savez on a bé
votre Doss en on a fait 3 He d'Internet
j'ai regardé et lu un certain nombre de
ses propos
euh
concernant je dirais la la médecine
concernant
l'éducation non non ça je n'ai pas
côtoyé ce ça c'est c'est une partie très
coursttillante quand même hein je n'en
doute pas mais quand je par mauva sens
du terme quand je parlais tout à l'heure
de racines ça ne fait pas partie des des
racines qui nous ont inspiré la la la
nef avec ce mot fraternel elle pose
clairement
en en pierre angulaire de de sa démarche
une ouverture à toutes les traditions
une ouverture à toutes les pensées quel
qu'ell soit nous sommes fondamentalement
laïqu et nous sommes vraiment avec
chevillé au corps un esprit de de non
violence de fraternité de bienveillance
vous trouvez la trace de ces mots dans
dans les chartes qui nous gouvernent
actuellement est-ce que vous pouvez
comprendre que sur Internet certains
vous reprochent d'être un peu comme la
je sais pas si le parallèle va être bon
ou si la parabole va être bonne mais on
vous reproche d'être un petit peu la
Scientologie de la
banque écoutez moi je suis respectueux
de de toutes les pensées y compris les
pensées critiques que dans vous êtes
respectueux de la Scientologie c'est
une c'est une secte en France c'est une
secte mais je ne les je ne les connais
pas je ne suis donc pas spécialement
respectueux de la Scientologie ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'effectivement
nous avons figurer comme un certain
nombre
d'institutions dans un un rapport
parlementaire de la fin des années 90
c'est la Mivilude non l'ancienne
Mivilude c'est ça non je crois que
c'était la Mivilude à l'époque euh
depuis nous je crois que mes mes
prédécesseurs on ont fait un une
instance judiciaire donc en en
diffamation le le nom de la nef a été
retiré de ces listes sectaires et pour
ma part quelle année ça
rappelez-moi la mémoire que j'en ai de
ce rapport parlementaire je dirais la
fin des années 90 d'accord
et la décision de justice à laquelle je
fais référence c'est début des années
2000 voilà à peu près les les les dates
auxquelles on se réfère moi quand je
suis arrivé dans l'environnement nef
après vous étiez dans les crédits
mutualistes c'est ça la banque
mutualiste moi j'ai fait toute ma
carrière dans des banques mutualistes et
coopératives
oui bon écoutez on va passer à autre
chose je la nef maintenant elle pèse
combien un bilan de 450 millions d'euros
un capital de 40 millions d'euros et
derrière ce capital vous avez 38000
sociétaires 40 million d'euros vous êtes
sûr c'est pas 39
oui c'est 39
950 je vous félicite de la euh de la
force de vos références
euh expliquez-moi un petit peu votre
cœur de business maintenant si je viens
chez vous je veux ouvrir un compte en
banque je peux ouvrir un compte courant
pas un compte courant qu'est-ce que je
peux faire chez vous imaginez-vous j'ai
100000 € à placer et bien notre cœur de
business comme vous dites c'est euh de
proposer au aux épargnants
euh de donner un sens à leur argent et
de leur donner une visibilité sur
l'utilisation que nous allons faire pour
financer des projets comme je l'aiévoqué
tout à l'heure à valeur ajoutée social
environnemental culturel donc des
projets qui sont dans dans cette
dynamique à côté de cette transparence
ce que nous mettons sur la table c'est
un j'allais dire une garantie ne
garantie sans rien du tout un présupposé
de comportement éthique euh avec cet
argent c'est quoi l'éthique bien
l'éthique c'est la vision propre que
nous emportons hein il y a pas d'éthique
absolue nous le sens que nous donnons à
à notre éthique et bien c'est en tant
que banque bien sûrin une éthique ça n'a
de sens que par rapport à à l'endroit où
on se pose sur le
monde bien nous nous nous posons sur le
monde en tant que banque et le sens que
nous donnons à notre éthique c'est c'est
notre vision de l'argent donc c'est un
comportement non spéculatif c'est un
comportement où nous ne faisons pas de
l'argent un outil d'appropriation
d'accumulation euh c'est un comportement
marqué par l'absence de rémunération
variable une échelle de salaire réduite
combien vous touchez net donc moi mon
mon mon salaire brut mensuel est de 7000
€. ce qui nous fait
5800 n ce qui doit faire 5 non vous
comptez certainement 23 ou 24 % de de de
de prélèvement donc euh
donc net dans les dans les
6000 6005 he ça doit être dans ces dans
ces eau là voilà non 5005 pardon 55 le
plus haut salaire chez vous c'est
combien c'est le mien donc 7000 € brut
par mois et juste en dessous c'est
combien le le deuxème salaire nous
sommes trop au Directoire mon mon mon
collègue le mieux payé derrière moi doit
être à 6005 et le plus bas
1800 je parle toujours en brut mensuel
et pour 1800 € on fait quoi chez vous et
bien on est euh on est gestionnaire
c'est-à-dire soit vous êtes dans un dans
dans un service pour traiter des
opérations bancaires soit vous êtes dans
une délégation commerciale euh pour être
en en assistance commerciale et
administrative vous gagnez combien dans
la banque mutualiste j'ai gagné plus
d'argent combien quand j'étais à la
directeur général de la banque fédérale
mutualiste je gag environ 200000 € par
an brut net
brut qu'est-ce qui vous a décidé de
changer écoutez je suis à un âge où on
pose on se pose pas mal de questions he
quel âge j'ai 62 ans donc j'ai décidé de
changer bien j'en avais j'en avais deux
ou trois de moins et donc quand on a
passé toute sa vie professionnel dans le
monde bancaire on on additionne des
questions quel genre de
questions quel sens ça a tout ça en quoi
la la finance peut être un outil de
construction du monde et non pas un
outil de destruction en quoi ça peut
être un outil de responsabilisation de
l'homme et et non pas
d'avilissement en quoi ça peut être un
un outil de financement de l'économie et
non pas de désagrégation des des
sociétés dans lesquelles nous sommes et
donc j'étais déjà au conseil de
surveillance à titre totalement bénévole
de laanf depuis 2004 et il y avait
quelque chose de de logique au moment où
une une porte professionnelle s'est
ouverte quand je dis porte
professionnelle ouverte ça veut dire que
ma mission
antérieure arrivé à sa fin et donc il y
avait un besoin au niveau de la nef et
c'est une sorte de de de logique
d'évidence pour moi aller venir finir ma
carrière dans cette coopérative vous
connaissez
bernardambert écoutez c'est un nom que
j'ai croisé là je ne peux pas vous dire
spontanément euh
quel est
le quelles sont les fonctions de
bernardbert mais c'est un nom que j'ai
certainement croisé dans mon parcours si
mes souvenirs sont bons il doit être
président d'honneur de l'École
polytechnique c'est ancien de la grande
banque rochield si mes souvenirs sont
bons mais je demande à la commun
vérifier qui a été conseillé de Pompidou
en ce moment il est en train de créer un
un comment un
conclave pour la moralisation du
capitalisme qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ce la moralisation du capitalisme et je
vais vous poser une autre question qui
est une question qui risque d'être posée
dans pas très longtemps avec le DAL Lama
la responsabilité
universelle écoutez la moralisation du
capitalisme nous nous ne pouvons qui
être favorable la démarche de laanf
c'est de ne donner des leçons de morale
à personne nous notre morale nous
cherchons à la mettre en œuvre à la
personnifier par notre façon d'être mais
si des des mouvements se se forme en
particulier initié par des des
professionnels de la finance et du
capitalisme en vue de moraliser
euh les les les
pratiques de cette de cette forme d'être
en société nous ne pouvons que nous en
réjouir nous-même nous n'avons aucune
prétention isolationniste nous sommes en
connexion avec la vraie vie donc nous
sommes en connexion avec la façon
d'exercer le métier de la banque tel
qu'il s'exerce aujourd'hui nous sommes
en connexion avec les marchés avec le
capitalisme nous avons beaucoup de
euh pas non seulement beaucoup de mais
nous font partie de nos gênnes les tout
ce qui peut être de l'ordre des
démarches entrepreneuriales euh donc on
s'en réjouit alors pour euh pour pour ce
qui concerne
euh le je dirais le le le le le sens que
ça peut euh que ça peut prendre pour
nous
euh et euh la votre allusion au euh donc
au au bien universel c'est cela euh la
responsabilité universelle donc nous
nous endossons totalement ce type de
démarche on met d'autres mots euh et
nous aimons bien mettre le mot de de
bien commun hein dans dans ce débat
euh pour nous il est très important que
les les projets économiques financiers
entrepreneuriaux que nous euh auquel
nous nous nous prêtons euh est très
important que on on y trouve euh un
petit exemple quand même des des petites
traces de bien commun ben l'exemple de
ce que nous finançons on va prendre
d'abord tout ce qui est lors de la
filière bio
euh et donc nous nous voyons des des des
résonances dans tous les entrepreneurs
qui s'inscrivent dans cette filière bio
nous voyons des des résonances avec
cette approche de de bien commun euh au
sens de respect de au sens de respect de
la planète et vous êtes
végan non non moi je suis très très
carnigore
personnellement j'adore j'adore une
entrecôte mais je ne suis pas végan mais
effectivement dans les sociétés rnef
vous devez certainement en trouver alors
vous êtes né le 2 janvier 1955 vous avez
été grand patron d'une banque non grand
patron moi jeai je nai 200 cas 200 cas
par je'ai je n'ai je n'ai dirigé que des
petites banques d'accord 200 cas par an
on va dire que c'est un salaire
confortable actuellement vous êtes
positionné sur quoi votre épargne il est
positionné sur quoi il est à la nef vous
avez transféré tout votre éparn à la nef
vous financez par vous-même des projets
à travers la nef vous êtes toujours dans
vos anciennes banquees vous avez mis vos
actifs dans différentes banques vous
êtes positionné en euros en dollars en
or en dollar canadien personnel
ouiah écoutez à titre personnel pour
améliorer le monde vous avez placé vos
Bill
oùésumre
personnel mon mon patrimoine familial et
immobilier et donc je je en France en
Belgique en France en France donc je
détiens ma résidence principale à
Montreuil avec mon épouse et toujours
avec avec elle nous détenons deux
appartements parisiens dans le 11e
arrondissement du liquide un peu
euh quelques dizaines de milliers
d'euros en en livret bancaire et puis ce
qu'on appelle un PERCO c'est-à-dire un
plan d'épargne retraite qui
est donc Quié à quoi qui est sur
des des des placements pour parti
obligataire pour partie Action géré par
la filiale d'éparne salariale de la
Société Générale vous avez confiance
dans la Société Générale sa capacité à
encaisser un choc financier oui est
est-ce que ces fonds souverains sont
suffisamment importants par rapport au
protocole de bal 4 alors ça je suis
incapable de de de de vous répondre ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai
côtoyé la société propre pardon c'est
que j'ai côtoyé la socioété
général lorsque j'ai dirigé la Bfm donc
pendant 12 ans c'était notre notre
partenaire commercial puisque c'était
par le biais de la Société Générale et
de son réseau euh qui était diffusé les
les offres bancaires de ce qui était à
l'époque la Banque fédérale mutualiste
maintenant devenue la banque française
mutualiste et moi j'ai j'ai j'ai vu
c'est pas une question de de confiance
hein j'ai j'ai vu les mes interlocuteurs
Société Générale œuvre j'ai travaillé
avec eux et j'ai un un respect
professionnel
pour les personnes de la Société
Générale avec lesquelles j'ai travaillé
est-ce que vous avez des du respect pour
des banques qui peuvent financer des
états totalitaires
prédateurs des actions contre
l'environnement par exemple il y a des
banques je ne citerai pas de nom
aujourd'hui mon avocat n'est pas encore
prévenu et des banques qui financeraient
des mines de cuivre qui dégueulassent
serait l'Argentine ou des des des
forages un peu CRCR il y a de l'éthique
quand même dans la banque écoutez à
titre personnel je je je regrette très
vivement que mes confrères financent ce
type d'activité et c'est vraiment vous
êtes au courant quand même que ça existe
je travaille dans le secteur bancaire
depuis près de 40 ans donc je j'ai une
connaissance qu'on qu'on peut qualifier
d'assez intime avec ce qui s'y passe
dans ce secteur bancaire y compris ces
turpitudes euh donc je je sais
parfaitement quelle déviance on peut y
trouver je sais parfaitement quel écarts
de comportement une certaine vision de
l'argent peut amener donc je je regrette
profondément ces déviations de du métier
que j'exerce euh donc je n'ai
aucuniation ou déviance bah les deux à
la fois si vous voulez parce que il y a
ce qui est de l'ORD de l'institution et
puis il y a ce qui est de du du ressort
des hommes qui la constitu euh dans
certaines situations les deux se
renforcent euh mais je sais aussi
combien des des personnes des
professionnels de la banque
parfaitement ancré dans des dans des
conviction honnêtes peuvent se
laisser circonscrire se laisser emporter
au-delà de là où ils aimeraient aller
fourvoyer fourvoyer oui tout à fait Z
c'est une ça peut être une pente
savonneuse ça peut être parfois des des
circonstances de de contrainte ou de
petite lâcheté une petite lâchetée peut
en amener une autre il y a une légende
urbaine qui dit que tous les banquiers
prennent de la cocaïne vous avez déjà
pris de la cocaïne écoutez non peut-être
d'ailleurs parfois vous savez euh dans
dans certains moments de difficulté hein
être dirigeant d'entreprise c'est pas
toujours très facile euh je je regrette
effectivement que que que que ma seule
turpitude soit un un verre d'alcool ici
ou là
euh je je je n'irai pas qu'un une petite
fumette de temps en temps m'aurait
peut-être fait un peu de bien quel type
de fumette j'aurais peut-être commencé
par juste une du bio ah écoutez je ne
sais pas si s'il existe du du cannabis
certifié bio c'est probablement un
marché qui sera assez porteur alors
est-ce que nous financerions une culture
de cannabis bio écoutez j'allais vous
poser la question d'ailleurs
spontanément j'aurais plutôt tendance à
regarder porter un regard amical sur un
projet comme ça mais je pense que notre
directeur de la conformité il trouverit
à redire en l'état actuel de la
législation bon on passera peut-être
vous voir après si tion évolue
euh je voudrais on voudrait avoir votre
perception des marchés financiers au
jour d'aujourd'hui cette cavalerie
financière par les banques centrales et
je voudrais avoir aussi votre perception
concernant
[Musique]
AEK on vous écoute oui écoutez ma
perception par rapport aujourd'hui au
aux politiques menées par les les
banques
centrales nous au niveau de la nef on on
n'est pas je vous parlerai ensuite de ma
réaction personnelle mais d'abord vous
dire quelle position nous au niveau de
la nef nous avons par rapport à à cette
situation et et par rapport aux
politiques macro-économiques qui sont
conduites nous on se sent à côté de
cette dynamique là
notre notre relation au marché c'est une
relation de coexistence mais tout
l'esprit de la nef c'est de de
construire sa propre logique de marché
l'esprit de la nef c'est d'être
autonome dans son accès à l'épargne
qu'elle utilise dans son accès à
l'argent qu'elle utilise donc nous nous
souhaitons et on peut dire que nous nous
sommes aujourd'hui entièrement dépendant
de nos clients et exclusivement de nos
clients pour accéder à la ressources que
nous réutilisons en crédit vous êtes
rentable non nous ne sommes présentement
pas rentable et depuis 2 ans nous
perdons de l'argent c'est sûr qu'en
payant des gens 7000
€ alors ça va me faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'honneur et d'importance de penser que
ce ce sont mes émoluments qui génèent
des pertes pour la une pique gratuite
non mais je vous en prie j'ai le j'ai le
cuir épis et très sincèrement j'aime
bien être un peu chatouillé ah ben il
fallz pas nous dire ça vous allez pas
être déçu du et bien écoutez que le que
le voyage continue mais pour reprendre
le le le fil de mon propos notre notre
rail notre ligne de conduite voyez notre
rail voyez vous m'emportez vous me
ramenez sur la coquille sur la trace
ouais bon mais
notre notre logique est bien de
construire une forme
d'écosystème indépendant des marchés
même si en tant que banque nous ne
pouvons pas prétendre que nous sommes
étanches par rapport au marché quoi
qu'il en soit la la vision que moi à
titre personnel je je porte sur la
politique de la Banque centrale
européenne on risque de vous surprendre
est plutôt positive euh moi je pour
quelle raison écoutez j'essaie de de
juger un arbre par ses fruits hein
et la la vision que que je peux avoir
c'est que la politique centrale la
politique de la Banque centrale
européenne a plutôt des conséquences
macroéconomiques positives sur ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier le la la la la marche
de l'économie en
général et les CR que je pourrais porter
sur la la politique économique ne sont
pas à ce niveau-là c'està-dire que pour
vous le fait que les banques centrale se
transforme en bad ban ça vous pose pas
de problème bah écoutez derrière ces bad
ban il a eu effectivement expliquez-nous
ce que c'est une une bad ban une bad
banque c'est une banque à l'intérieur de
laquelle vous vous trouvez des des
crédits que les clients ne peuvent pas
rembourser alors le vrai mot c'est des
crédits pourris des crédits pourris des
junk bonds savez comptablement on a
appelle on appelle ça dans un bilan
bancaire des créances compromises et et
ça veut dire quoi douteuse et compromise
hein c'est c'est le terme comptable ou
des prêts à neutron c'est pas mal mais
si vous voulez que la Banque centrale
européenne reprenne à son
compte des crédits pourris comme vous le
dites je le dis c'est la réalité c'est
la réalité de de la part de banques qui
ont engrangé dans un peut-être une
propenstion exagérée à à on dit on dit
comment proportion exagérée on dit se
gaver oui mais derrière ça vous avez des
banques qui ont qui ont financé aussi
des crédits à l'économie même si ces
crédits n'ont pas donné lieu à
remboursement l'effet de levier de la
Deutsch Bank c'est combien alors c'est
c'est gigantesque je je peux pas vous le
dire de mémoire mais c'est vrai que la
doutge Bank est un magnifique exemple
des des déviances ou des gigantesque
c'est c'est un ordre de grandeur combien
une
fourchette écoutez ce que ce que ce que
je sais c'est que
le si on on compare la nef et la Deutsch
Bank si vous
comparez d'un côté le le rapport de cap
grand sable et le la deutge Bank le
rapport de capital entre la nef et la
deutge Bank et de l'autre côté le
rapport de bilan de la nef et de la
Deutsch Bank euh si je je peux pas vous
donner les chiffres exacts mais si on
prenait pour hypothèse que le rapport
entre le capital de la nef et de la
Dodge ban était de 1 à 100 le rapport de
bilance serait de l'ORD de 1 à 1000 donc
avec la avec le même capital on peut
dire que la la Deutch Bank a
effectivement joué de l'effet de levier
mais surtout ce que je voudrais
dire c'est
que ce rôle de la Banque centrale
européenne pour essayer de remettre un
peu d'ordre dans ces déviances bancaires
sauf qui peut n'est pas jugé sévèrement
de la place qui est la mienne par contre
ce
que je regrette davantage c'est la la
vision que la Banque centrale européenne
a dans sa façon d'approcher la
supervision bancaire c'est-à-dire le
financement réel non
euh si vous voulez le prê sans regarder
non c'est pas ça que je veux dire le le
thermomètre principal qui est utilisé
par la Banque centrale européenne et
l'ensemble des autorités bancaires
européennes pour superviser pour réguler
le système bancaire ça s'appelle le
ratio de sol ilité c'est quoi le ratio
de solvabilité c'est une bête fraction
vous avez au numérateurs les fonds
propres c'est le capital et les réserves
et puis vous avez au dénominateur les
risques c'estàdire les crédits et
l'approche politique de de la Banque
centrale est une approche neutre
c'est-à-dire que la banque centrale
au-delà de du réglage du thermomètre
elle dit le ratio doit être de temps
mais elle dit peu m'importe je simplifie
mais globalement c'est ce qu'elle dit
peu m'importe ce qui est financé hein si
au dénominateur dans les risques de
crédit qui sont à couvrir par le
numérateur le capital collecté auprès
des actionnaires et et et des euh des
coopérateurs parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
banques qui sont coopérativ peu mimporte
ce que vous faites de cet argent que que
vous financiez comme on le disait tout à
l'heure éventuellement de la du trafic
de drogue ou que vous financiez des
armes pas du trafic de drogue de la
consommation Excell je m'égare euh que
vous financiez du trafic d'armes que
vous financiez de la pornographie des
activités mafieuses ou peut-être des des
besoins du du Vatican pour aller au au
SOMUM de la vertu et bien peu m'importe
et donc je regrette que euh les autor en
Dieu disons que euh ma ma croyance
personnelle a pas beaucoup d'importance
mais on va dire que on va dire que je
fais comme si c'est c'est-à-d vous
croyez à une force supérieure oui je
crois une force supérieure vous avez un
ami un ami
imaginaire un ami
imaginaire un ami imaginaire écoutez là
m'emporter sur comme ça en spontané
peut-être sur des terrains que j'avais
pas imaginé on va dire mon ange gardien
oui je pense qu'il a il y a une force
supérieure qu'on lui mette ou non le nom
de Dieu sur dessus me paraît pas
forcément très important mais c'est
important pour rentrer à la ne d'avoir
des croyances non non mais quand même
vous vous dire que ma ma tradition
personnelle est une tradition catholique
donc j'ai j'ai les bonnes références
catholiques et je suis perméable au aux
enseignements de de l'Évangile chrétien
oui continuez votre raésonnement
concernant les banques centrales et donc
ce que je regrette c'est que les
autorités politiques ne se soient pas
saisis de ce fameux dénominateur du
ratio de solvabilité parce que et là je
reprends la casquette nef de notre point
de vue il n'est pas indifférent de
savoir ce qu'on fin et et financer une
activité a et bien pour le bien-être
sociétal c'est pas la même chose que de
financer l'activité B et et donc il nous
semble qu'une démarche politique
élémentaire pourrait consister à se
rapprocher des autorité de la Banque
centrale européenne pour leur dire bien
nous politiques nous avons une pensée à
formuler sur la façon dont on calculle
ce dénominateur et sur les les
pourcentages de pondération qu'on
pourrait appliquer à différentes natures
de crédit et donc considérer qu'il y a
des natures de crédit qui sont
politiquement plus désirables que
d'autres plus soutenables que d'autres
euh et qui juge de ça comment qui juge
de ça c'est un bord qui se concerte
aujourd'hui personne puisque il a été
posé en en en principe fondateur de la
Banque centrale européenne qu'elle était
autonome par rapport au pouvoir
politique et et donc nous nousf je vais
peut-être dire jeu parce que là ce
serait beaucoup faire beaucoup parler
mes mes mes collègues et et et les
instances qui m'entourent pour employer
le nous mais je dirais qu'à titre
personnel je je considère qu'il est il
aurait été souhaitable de de limiter la
zone d'autonomie d'indépendance de la
Banque centrale européenne à son
activité de régulation de l'inflation et
que pour ce qui concerne la régulation
du secteur bancaire on puisse créer un
lien avec le politique pour que
cette ces décisions relatives à la
pondération des différents crédits qui
rentrent dans dans ce dénominateur
relève de la décision politique
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fond de
garantie des dépôts bancaires français
bien écoutez j'en pense du bien j'en
pense du bien parce que préparer votre
cuir parce que là ça va piquer enfin
j'en pense du bien sur le principe je
crois que il est très important de
pouvoir offrir une sécurité au au
déposants on a vu à travers différents
épisodes de
crise au au cours des des temps passés
qu'il y avait des effets de contagion je
vous laisse vous enterrer ou laissez-moi
m'enterrer qui avait des effets je me
redéterrerai peut-être avec votre aide
tout à
l'heure il me paraît très important euh
d'induire de la de la sécurité au niveau
du du déposant pour essayer de couper
cours aux effets de de panique aux
effets de contagion et donc je crois
qu'un un système de de garantie
mutualisé entre les banques sur les
dépôts de leurs clients et et et sain
dans une économie ouverte comme la nôtre
quelle est la taille bon allez on
commence là on est chaud quelle est la
taille du fond de garantie des bancaires
en France ben cette taille est minime
hein j'ai c'est quoi minime bah écoutez
je peux pas vous dire de de de chiffre
précis ce que je peux dire c'est que ce
fond de garantie ne doit couvrir comme
ça un ordre de grandeur que quelques
pourcen hein quelques petits
pourcentages c'est combien par contre
est parétablissement mais la la la
garantie doit être de l'ordre de 100000
€ par 70 je si mes souvenirs sont 72
72000 € mais par banque et par compte
par par par client oui et et ça fait
beaucoup pas beaucoup si on se prend un
petit un petit choc sur les banques à
votre avis est-ce que c'est suffisamment
dimensionné pour
encaisser un choc alors le fond de
garantie si vous le limitez aux sommes
qui sont déposées dans ces caisses
aujourd'hui serait dans la capacité de
faire face à un choc massif c'est quoi
un choc massif bah un choc massif c'est
bah écoutez au lieu de faire chutter
Liman BRS vous faites
chuter
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas vous faites
chuter les les grandes banques
américaines vous faites chuter les les
plus grandes banques mondiales et on
fait comment pour faire chuter les plus
grandes banques mondiales B
écoutez on laisse penser qu'elles ne
pourront pas honorer leur échéances du
lendemain mais pour en revenir à cette
idée de mutualisation des des des
risques à l'intérieur du système
bancaire je pense que c'est ça qu'une
forme de garantie solidaire relie les
banques entre elles géré par l'État et
cette forme de garantie mutuelle de mon
point de vue a plutôt des effets
vertueux que des effets vicieux
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du glass
stigle
Act écoutez pas grand-chose hein je je
ne prétends pas être un un un théoricien
de la finance internationale au niveau
de la séparation des banques d'affaires
et de mon parcours je suis assez
franco-français maintenant je vais quand
même tenter de répondre hein sur le ce
ce glace Stig Act euh il y a eu des des
véités en France he pour essayer d'en
faire une transposition ou tout au moins
en Europe vités qui n'ont pas abouti
pour la la séparation des des des
banques d'affaires et et des banques de
détail
écoutez sur le plan du du principe moi
j'y suis plutôt favorable je ne suis pas
persuadé que ça soit le bon endroit pour
pour porter le le faire Sion se on
revient à cette volonté de de
moralisation du du métier de la banque
et de l'usage de l'argent je suis pas
persuadé que euh ça soit l'endroit
névralgique où il faillent porter lesffs
je pense qu'on peut être aussi vereux
euh dans le métier de la banque de
détail que dans le métier de la banque
d'affaires euh je pense que la
fondamentalement la la question n'est
pas là de toute façon à un moment ou un
autre l'épargne accumulée par la banque
de détail euh peut toujours trouver le
moyen de se recycler euh dans les
métiers de la banque d'affaires à
travers le les les financements de
marché euh donc mon sentiment
euh serait que il faudrait mieux aborder
cette volonté de moralisation et et et
de vertu et de remise de la banque au
service de l'économie par d'autres biais
vous empruntez auprès de la BCE nous
n'empruntons pas auprès de la BCE nous
sommes nous dans une démarche que
j'avais qualifié tout à l'heure
d'écosystème où nous nous nous
refinanons pour employer ce ce mot
bancaire auprès de nos propres
clients
bon qu'est-ce que je vais vous poser
comme
question je réfléchis les les le shadow
banking ça vous fait penser à quoi bah
le shadow banking ça me fait d'abord
penser au au fameux au fameux hedge
F et donc là je pense qu'on aurait un
angle
d'attaque beaucoup plus intéressant que
pour porter le fer pour porter le fer
oui oui quand quand quand je vois
la la l'enrichissement
absolument débile c'est même pas
délirant hein c'est c'est de l'ordre de
la pathologie au auquel l'enrichissement
personnel en faveur des des actionnaires
et grands gérants C fun auquel donne
accès l'exercice de ce métier je pense
qu'on là on a une illustration de la
capacité de de certains acteurs de la
finance à être prédateur sur l'ensemble
des circuits financiers euh qui qui me
paraît
être de l'ordre de voilà du maladie hein
de notre de système financier et
euh ma ma mon élan personnel pour
essayer de porter le fer hein dans dans
cette pathologie donc serait d'attaquer
la chose différemment je pense que le un
petit coup de tison sur la MF non non
non euh je je pense qu'un des points
névralgiques mais bien identifié et qui
fait l'objet de nombreuses tentatives
est vraiment celui des paradis fiscaux
je je pense que c'est ces paradis
fiscaux sont l'exemple même de la
gangraine qui est au au cœur de notre
système financier au cœur de notre
système capitaliste qui n'est pas
uniquement à œuvre d'ailleurs dans le
système financier hein puisque une
gangraine ou une
cavalerie moi j'assimilerai ça à de la
gangraine à des cellules
cancéreuses alors après évidemment des
mécanismes de cavalerie peuvent
s'organiser autour de ça de déis comment
de
dénis non je crois pas de dénis parce
que je pense que tout le monde a les
yeux parfaitement ouverts sur ces
réalités là de plus en plus les gens
sont informé de ce qui se passe ils
comprennent ce qui se passe bah écoutez
je crois que oui vous avez bah il y a
une lecture
récente je crois que c'est c'est c'est
Oxfam qui vient de de publier son la
nouvelle édition de son son rapport sur
la transparence vous avez des des ONG
euh très très actives lesquel bah vous
avez notamment transparency et puis en
France vous avez une une ONG don don le
nom mais'est pas présent à l'esprit là
mais aussi qui uvre
avec beaucoup
de je dirais de persévérance sur ces
questions là vous avez aussi les les
grands organismes internationaux qui
sont sont saisis he de cette question
des paradis fiscaux à commencé par
l'OCDE mais les les progrès sont sont
extrêmement lents et- que c'est à dessin
que les progrès sont
lentsez le doute est permis le le doute
est permis mais il me
semble
que je pense qu'une volonté politique un
peu plus chevillé au corps un peu plus
chevill à l'âme d'ailleurs surtout
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par âme et
bien là on refait le lien avec cette
dimension transcendanteiner c'est ça non
non vous savez je ne crois pas que
Steiner soit propriétaire en quoi que ce
soit de la de la transcendance c'est de
la démarche spirituelle ell l'ont
précédé de de beaucoup hein ça n'a été
qu'un qu'un qu'un acteur parmi des des
milliers d'autres et certainement pas le
plus ant sur ces terrainlà mais sur la
la question de des paradis fiscaux quand
on voit dans le rapport d'Oxfam que des
pays comme la la Belgique comme le
Luxembourg comme l'Irlande sont
assimilé à des paradis fiscaux et que
notamment pour parler de la Belgique et
du Luxembourg que là nous avons deux
pays fondateurs de la Communauté
économique européenne on on on se dit
que le le le vert est dans le fruit et
et que c'est bien par là qu'il faudrait
commencer à à l'attaquer et s'il y avait
une une initiative politique que
j'appellerai de mes vœux ben c'est moi
je me rangerai volontiers vers ceux qui
appellent à une initiative
franco-allemande he pour
relancer l'Europe sur d'autres bases et
en particulier euh tout ce qui peut être
lié à à à l'harm isationtion fiscale
européenne je pense que nos les deux
grands pays qui sont au cœur de l'Europe
là auraient les moyens et une
responsabilité déterminante j'ai cité la
Belgique et c'est pas du wishful sing ça
comment c'est pas du wishful sing si un
peu un peu mais si vous voulez le wish
wishf thinking c'est mon mauvais anglais
he ça ça fait partie aussi de de la
démarche volontaire
initiale les grandes idées
partent aussi euh peuvent aussi partir
euh de wishful thinking ça n'est pas
interdit de l'espérer bon mais vraiment
au niveau de la nef
euh mais écoutez nous à notre petite
notre petite échelle on essaie de de de
de personnifier une autre façon de faire
et on dans dans notre positionnement on
va être plus actif en en tentant de de
démontrer par l'acte que euh de
construire de de savantes pensées bon
alors imaginez-vous j'ai 100000 € je
veux changer de banque
oui alors jeis très très content de la
mienne pour
l'instant peut-être pas très éthique sur
certains points est-ce qu'on peut faire
ouvrir un compte pour les particuliers
chez vous non pourquoi parce que nous
n'avons pas l'agrément pour le faire
pourquoi bien c'est une question qu'il
faudrait poser à l'Autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et de résolution c'estàdire
le bras armé de la Banque de France pour
réguler secteur bancaire nous
avons demandé en 2014 ex d'agrément nous
avons obtenu le droit d'ouvrir des
comptes de de professionnels et
d'entreprises nous avons obtenu le droit
d'ouvrir des comptes surlivré pour les
particuliers des livré B des livré B
mais nous n'avons pas obtenu le droit
d'ouvrir des des comptes
bancaires l'autorité de contrôle nous a
estimé insuffisamment prêt d'un point de
vue opérationnel et technique
sincèrement elle a pas forcément tort et
donc ça reste pour nous en ligne de mire
mais pour l'instant il nous faut d'abord
digérer l'étape d'extension que nous
sommes en
train de de de mettre en œuvre donc si
vous avez 100000 € vous pouvez les
déposer chez nous soit sur un livret
rémunéré à 0,10 % c'est moins que
l'inflation c'est-à-dire bien moins que
l'inflation ça sert à rien de mettre
votre mon pognon chez vous ça dépend
quel est le sens que vous donnez au mot
servir donc effectivement pour vos
finances personnelles ça sert à rien je
suis assez d'accord qu'est-ce qui
pourrait me donner envie ben écoutez
financez quoi comment je peux le voir
est-ce que tous les mois j'ai un petit
bilan de qui se passe chez vous histoire
de me motiver à perdre du FR chez
essayie de de donner un peu de sens à
l'argent qui nous est confié donc ce qui
pourrait vous donner envie c'est c'est
c'est c'est l'idée que cet argent bien
nous en faisons des des petites choses
qui peuvent être peut-être se connecter
avec un réseau de personnes qui ont
envie de changer le monde non
ou la finance d'abord c'est une c'est
une façon d'y
contribuer les garanties sur tout ça et
bien vous n'avez aucune garantie
particulière si
la nef fait faillite et
bien vous vous vous vous serez logé
comme n'importe quel autre client
bancaire la même source avec la fameuse
garantie des dépôts à laquelle vous
sembliez attacher du prix tout à l'heure
c'est pas qu'on semble attacher du prix
mais quand on voit la volatilité des
marchés comment les marchés sont un
petit peu instrumentalisés comme dans
l'exunion soviétique parce que il y a
plus vraiment de prix vous êtes pas
d'accord avec moi les prix sur les
marchés financiers sont pas
administré écoutez ça dépend de quel
marché financier on parle ce qui est
extrêmement administré c'est le marché
des taux courts ça c'est clair la Banque
centrale européenne à travers ses ses
taux de référence à la main mise
entièrement sur les taux cours
euh pour le reste quand on voit la la
volatilité sur les les taux longs quand
on voit la volatilité sur les taux
actions même si la volatilité en ce
moment est plutôt assez faible vix le
VIX il est combien aujourd'hui là
comment le VIX est à combien aujourd'hui
aucune
idée ça fait pas partie des indicateurs
qui sont dans dans mon radar quels sont
les indicateurs dans votre radar et bien
donc le le taux de lorbor 3 mois le le
taux de que vous pensez des
manipulations sur le rebor oh bien là
j'en pense tout tout le mal possible
vous pouvez me résumer un petit peu et
bien ce sont des nous résumé pardon et
bien si vous voulez le Reb 3 mois c'est
donc le le le le taux auquel les les
banques
s'échangent l'argent en euros et toutes
les toutes les banques européennes voire
mondiales interviennent sur ce marché de
l'euro pour se prêter s'emprunter de
l'argent au jour le jour pour se faire
et bien elles ont des on va dire des
employés qu'on appelle des traders hein
qui sont qui sont dédiés à ce job là et
donc un certain nombre de de traders euh
se sont entendus euh
entre banques pour manipuler les les
cours pour
transmettre
au aux organes de compensation euh
publiant les les indices des taux moyens
traités par jour s'arrangeant pour leur
communiquer des fausses informations et
donc en tirant des profit probablement
euh très équitablement partagés entre
leur profit personnel et le profit de
leur institution pour faire simple bon
en gros ils sont gavés avec la Vale de
leur hiérarchie c'est ça disons que
certaines hiérarchies étaient
probablement au courant mais je ne veux
pas faire de de procès plus que ça il
est possible que certaines hiérarchies
n'ai pas été au courant je n'en sais
rien mais ce sont des des déviations qui
ont fait l'objet de de de lourdes
sanctions qu'est-ce que vous appelez
lourde ça c'est intéressant bien écoutez
un certain nombre de banques ont eu des
des des sanctions se chiffrant en
centaines de millions ou ou ou en
milliards et puis euh quelle quelle
banque a pris quelques milliards là qui
écoutez là vous me je les banques qui
ont été sanctionnées sur ce marché je à
ma connaissance une bon est-ce que la
sanction était à la hauteur des profits
réalisés je n'en sais rien en tout cas
une bonne partie des grandes banques
internationales a été sanctionné sur les
manipulations du marché de l' ribor donc
revenons au départ vous nous parliez de
le ribor
oui comme étant à des taux que je
suivais de près voilà oui vous le suivez
il est manipulé vous l'avez dans dans
écoutez aucune idée pour savoir s'il est
encore
manipulé j'ose espérer que les instances
professionnelles qui ont été mandatés
pour cela ont fait en sorte de supprimer
les déviations antérieures je n'en ai
aucune aucune idée aucune garantie les
autres les autres indices que vous
surveillez et bien euh le taux de de
l'obligation française à 10
ans et puis euh qui est à combien
aujourd'hui écoutez selon les jours et
au alentours de 1
% avec
des des variations quotidiennes qui
peuvent être significatives c'est pour
ça que je réagissais un peu quand vous
disiez que les les marchés étaient
complètement administré
administré non on peut encore
rassurez-vous il y a encore de beau
jours pour la spéculation et sur un
instrument aussi aussi standard si je
puis dire que l'obligation française à
ans vous avez des des des variations
quotidiennes qui qui laissent encore de
belles jour aux
spéculation vous êtes plutôt putuption
ou
co non je je ne suis absolument pas
intervenant sur le marché des options
vous l'avez été
écoutez il m'est arrivé effectivement
dans d'opération tion de de couverture
lorsque j'étais directeur financier dans
la banque qui m'employait à l'époque de
de te traiter des opérations d'option
oui vous vous couvriez contre quoi bien
nous avions des des des placements à
taux à taux variable donc nous
cherchions à à couvrir le le risque de
vous étiez exposé sur quoi sur le Suisse
sur quoi non non
c'était nous étions des des intervenants
franco-français donc c'était
là je vous parle de la fin des années 80
euh et donc c'était ce qu'on appelle à
l'époque le franc je sais pas si vous en
souvenez vous êtes jeune donc vous
peut-être que vous n'avez pas connu cet
époque le franc lourd c'est ça bah
écoutez c'était le franc tout court dans
la fin de ces années 80 c'était le franc
tout court et les nouveau franc le
nouveau franc ou là là mais le nouveau
franc c'est bien avant non non on a le
terme nouveau franc ça doit dater des
années 60 ça doit être monsieur ça vous
êtes né en 1955 oui oui oui non j'ai
j'ai j'ai connu la période où on m' a
parlé de de Monsieur Pinet hein euh mais
est-ce que vous êtes pour le retour au
Fran non non assurément non vous êtes
pour l'Euro je je je ne suis ni pour
l'Euro ni pour le franc je vais je vais
vous faire vousêtes pour le business
responsable non c'est pas ce que
j'allais vous dire même si oui je suis
pour le business responsable mais
surtout par rapport à ça si vous voulez
euh que ce soit mon moneste au niveau
personnel au niveau de la nef nous nous
ne sommes pas des des des des des des
praticiens d'une d'une chapelle en tant
que telle pour ou contre l'euro c'est
c'est pas notre sujet principal la
création monétaire ça vous parle je vais
vous en parler là mais je vrais juste
finir la MA ma réaction sur cette
question de pour ou contre l'euro nous n
nous nous sommes intrincèquement
fondamentalement
contre contre l'élévation de de Chapell
de frontières de de de murs nous sommes
pour ce qui rapprochent les hommes nous
essayons d'être cohérent avec notre
démarche fraternelle
et lorsque nous nous nous voyons des des
frontières qui s'élèvent entre les
hommes quelqu soit l'endroit où elle
s'élève je parle pas uniquement des
frontières territoriales et
diplomatiqu ça nous inquiète nous ne
sommes pour
une circulation la plus libre possible
mais évidemment une circulation encadrée
par des règles qui permettent à cette
circulation d'être responsable nous
avions il y a peu de temps un un projet
européen à la fin des années 2000 on
avait formulé avec une consure italienne
qui s'appelle la banque la banque
atica qui est
vraiment typiquement dans la même
démarche que nous ils sont beaucoup plus
gros que nous en Italie ils sont plus
anciens que nous et et ils
essayent là où ils sont de devrait dans
la même direction nous avions formulé il
y avait un 3ise Laron dans l'histoire
céit un partenaire espagnol beaucoup
plus petit du nom de fiaré et nous
avions formulé un projet de de fusion
transfrontalière Espagne France Italie
euh donc ce projet a échoué euh que des
économies pourris quoi euh oui mais des
gens pas pourris du tout hein vous savez
ce qui nous importe c'est surtout les
les les gens qui gravident dans ces
économies économies pourri je sais pas
trop ce que ça veut dire je ne connais
que des que des gens pourris ou des gens
non pourris et c'est eux qui font ou non
les économies pourres toujours é-il que
ce projet européen a échoué nous nous le
regrettons beaucoup euh
probablement les temps ne sont pas
encore mûes
pour organiser de façon fluide des des
des fusions transfrontalière que ce soit
dans l'économie responsable
ou dans l'économie éthique enfin quel
que soit le le nom que nous donnions
maintenant oui nous sommes effectivement
pour une
économie responsable bien sûr même si le
monde responsable c'est un mot à
beaucoup d'entrée à prendre avec des
pincettes l'argent dette la création
monétaire qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ou la création monétaire bah
écoutez c'est c'est une question qui ne
peut pas laisser indiérent un banquier
hein puisque le le banquier c'est c'est
l'artisan deartisan je pense que ça va
pas là avec banquier non si si si si
mais si mais si mais n'ayyez pas cette
cette image vous
savez chez les banquers vous trouvez
aussi bien des des des grossistes des
grossistes que que que des
que des ouvriers en passant par des des
des artisans vous avez 36000 façons
d'organiser votre rapport à l'argent du
du du pire au meilleur hein ne l'oubliez
pas toujours est-il que la création
monétaire euh nous nous nous en sommes
des des modestes opérateurs à à
l'échelle qui est la nôtre hein lorsque
nous réalisons un crédit euh à partir de
rien vous créez alors à partir de rien
euh je pense que c'est une une vision
qui qui est un peu rapide euh et bien il
faut juste avoir en tête comment
fonctionne un bilan de banque vous
m'avez pas parlé de Kees tout à l'heure
on va revenir sur ce sujet non parler de
Haek pardon excusez-moi bien vu écoutez
non là très
sincèrement je suis incapable de vous
parler de la théorie de Haek pourquoi
parce que je je l'ignore vous êtes
kénésien à fond non je ne suis pas
kénésien moi je suis je je suis pas trop
théoricien économique hein je je je suis
j'aime bien aller de du particulier au
général j'aime bien théoriser à mes
heures mais plutôt à partir de de ma
réalité professionnelle observée donc
c'est plutôt la l'artisan qui devient
philosophe autour du du du du verre de
vin auquel je faisais référence tout à
l'heure quand la du
microcrédit alors oui mais attendez la
création monétaire un instant ça ça va
pas assez vite c'est pour ça qu'on oui
oui oui mais
écoutez vous avez évoqué la création
monétaire vous voulez un petit peu de
Red Bull un petit peu de Red Bull ben
écoutez pourquoi pas non il y en a plus
bon c'est dommage parce que j'ai ça
c'est fait exprès d'habitude on met la
pièce à 8°gr non non mais ça m'aurait
peut-être fait accélérer hein toujours
est-il que la création monétaire il faut
bien avoir en tête comment est fait un
bilan de banque si vous avez du mal à
vous endormir le soir n'hésitez pas à
regarder un un bilan de banque ça vous
aidera mais un bilan de banque il a une
partie passif une partie actif hein et
euh donc la la partie crédit elle est à
l'actif mais cet actif et bien il est il
est financé par le passif et le passif
c'est tout simplement les dépôts des
clients donc nous aujourd'hui euh nous
nous prétendons
que nous ne faisons de création
monétaire qu'à la hauteur permise par
les clients par les dépôts qu'il nous
confie he c'est c'est notre façon de
vraer en création monétaire évidemment
pour une banque qui se refinance
entièrement sur les
marché le propos peut être un peu plus
nuancé mais voilà nous en tout cas la
conception que nous avons de la création
monétaire la la la la relié entièrement
à l'épargne qui nous est confiée euh
pour vraiment
euh faire en sorte que euh mais là je
commence à m'égarer sur le planc la
finance à la papa non c'est que l'argent
relie les hommes hein c'est euh le
slogan d'ANF l'argent rel encore au
moins une fois ça d'accord
oui alors je vous disiez quoi là Kees
non AEK AEK non là AEK non là c'est quoi
votre votre façon pour euh oh comment on
va formuler ça les gars ça va être chaud
ça votre prisme de lecture globale sur
ce qui ce qui est en train de se passer
donc il y a une perte de sens dans le
financement de l'économie c'est ça vous
m'arrêtez si je me trompe bien écoutez
non je dirais pas ça qu'est-ce que vous
diriez alors bien je je dirais que oui
la perte de sens dans l'économie oui
mais je je dirais
que on est sur une pente qui est pas
forcément incliné dans le sens qu'on
imagine
et observation que je peux faire donc
nourri de bien du du métier que j'exerce
c'est
que la pente elle est plutôt orientée
dans le sens de la remontée je je je
pense
que à l'échelle du système bancaire
français pour parler de ce que je
connais le mieux on est dans une pente
on est en train de remonter la pente et
que le système bancaire français est en
train progressivement avec bien
sûr peut-être euh
euh à redire ici ou là mais le système
bancaire français est en train de
remonter cette pente de mise au service
de l'économie aujourd'hui
oui vous en êtes
persuadé c'est ce que euh c'est ce que
j'observe il faut avoir il faut avoir à
l'esprit qu'aujourd'hui euh plus des
tris/4 du du du marché de la ce qu'on
appelle la banque de détail en France et
est détenue par des banques
coopératives
des banques comme la Société Générale ou
ou BNPP ne détiennent que des pars de
marché minoritaires sur sur le monondque
de la bande de détail en France les les
grands acteurs c'est groupe Crédit
Agricole Crédit Mutuel banque CIC donc
CIC Crédit Mutuel Crédit Mutuel CIC
crédit cré la banque pche c'est ça CIC
Banque P Crédit Mutuel non c'est pas ça
euh écoutez euh probablement et la la
banque pche est une est une fial CIC je
je je je vous la connaissez la banque
pche non je connais pas plus que ça non
toujours est-il que euh ces grandes
banques ont me semble-t-il tiré des
premières conclusions de la crise
financière de 2008 et et et j'observe à
l'intérieur de ces grandes maisons une
une volonté réelle de remettre de
l'ordre dans les boutiques Frédéric oua
il a plus du tout de de paradis fiscaux
à la Société générale c'est ça je
parlais des grandes manques mutualiste
et coopératives je je serais
effectivement moins affirmatif sur ce
qui se passe sur les autres banques mais
je parle du du monde des banques
coopératives à l'intérieur de des
banques coopératives à l'intérieur
duquel n nous évoluons et on peut
observer en
particulier un phénomène de
reterritorialisation avec une véritable
volonté de toutes les banques coopérativ
de de de relier l'épargne collecté
avec l'activité économique de leur
territoire on vient de loin euh et donc
on ne gomme pas les déviances du du
passé d'un trait de plume mais moi il me
semble observer de la place où je
suis qu'il y a une une dynamique plutôt
encourageante
espérons-leou bon microcrédit on fait du
microcrédit à la nef alors on fait du
microcrédit professionnel notre crédit
moyen à la nef c'est 100000 € notre
médiane c'est 40000 € et on a une
proportion substantielle dans nos crédit
qui est inférieur à 25000 € donc c'est
ce qu'on pourrait qualifier de
microcrédit alors il faut s'entendre sur
ce qui est financé à travers ces crédits
là donc nous nous finançons des des des
projets de création d'entreprises quels
qu'on soient les secteurs ça peut être
des des projets dans le monde agricole
ça peut être des projets
dans le domaine de la distribution dans
le domaine de la transformation ça peut
être des projets culturels mais nous
sommes assez présents à quel
taux écoutez sur un microcrédit nous
nous allons intervenir à des taux entre
3 et 4
%. j'ai pas bien compris he votre taux à
vous c'est 3 4 % sur un microcrédit ça
va être un ordre de grandeur oui c'est
parce que c'est risqué le microcrédit
chez
vous alors d'une part c'est risqué et et
et d'autre part il y a il y a juste un
détail qu'on oublie c'est que les les
les heures de travail des personnes qui
instruisent ces microcrédits il faut les
rémunérer aujourd'hui not notre activité
de microcrédit est lourdement
déficitaire même avec les taux que nous
pratiquons c'est une des difficultés de
la nef et et donc aujourd'hui je je peux
affirmer même si je suis jugé parti dans
ce que je vais vous dire que le déficit
de la nef est davantage dû à à sa
problématique d'équilibrage de son
activité de microcrédit que de
rémunération de son dirigeant vous
devancez ma question bon on arrive à la
fin de notre interview hélas
euh on a une question qui est récurrente
c'est laisser une bouteille à la mer
pour les jeunes générations on est sur
internet donne un conseil aux jeunes
générations maintenant tout de suite sur
le sujet que vous voulez
entreprenez entreprenez prenez votre
destin en main ne comptez pas sur je ne
sais
quel appuis systémique ne comptez pas
sur je ne sais quel miracle politique
nous sommes dans un monde qui et je
parle avec le le recul d'un vieil homme
qui qui de mon point de vue a ouvert
comme jamais le champ est'est possible
pour quelqu'un qui a l'esprit de vie et
d'entreprise chevillé au
corps laanf sera prête à vous encourager
dans ce sens est-ce que vous avez une
question à nous
poser bien
écoutez je ne sais pas dites-moi comment
vous avez vécu cette heure ça a été un
bon moment pour
vous il faut que je demande à m
collègues parce que en fait on plug nos
cerveaux on fait comme une seule entité
ça a été ça a été c'est bon pas d'autre
question
non bon c'est un peu fait chier
quoi bon euh non je blague he peut-être
pas il y a toujours un fond de vérité
dans ce qu'on
dit on était très content de vous
recevoir on était très
content d'aborder tout de suite le sujet
de Steiner de Prim à abord parce que
c'est dans notre communauté un point
d'adhérence qui en a stressé euh chez
nous on écoute tout le monde y compris
des papiers assassins sur la nef
euh merci d'avoir essayé d'avoir la plus
grande franchise à notre égard et puis
voilà merci merci à
[Musique]
vous